hard money
yes Stephanie
hey Draymond we're here
that's what we're looking for
they've been waiting on that
is you watch your Shadow so you don't
want your Shadow to be in his line so
you just draw a straight line
a little bit early but not a lot late
you don't want to get a technical foul
out here people shadows and not
replacing your divots and stuff like
that I teach this man some etiquette
Draymond is a source of confident
encouragement
you should uh I mean if y'all wanted an
inside scoop in our locker room you're
getting it right now
full flesh
three more years baby come on dream on
hey Steph are you feeling okay you're a
little stiff from the fender bender back
there
call my lawyer right quick
I gotta call my lawyer right now
it was a chain reaction me we can do a
little class action lawsuit against him
right quick
or you can sue both of them I think you
should sue them both but no that's a
Buffalo Bills trying to get me in the
off season
I'm trying to chill have some fun at the
golf course
you never know
[Applause]
this way this way
[Music]
can we call like a 30 seconds
for the win
already
and you never know
that was the time
this way
it's all good Straight TV